♪ [upbeat music plays]
Scott Drake: So, some of the core benefits
when we looked at building a Google TV app,
about 30, 40 percent of our content
has real time market data in there.
When we understood that there was
an opportunity to work with Google
to be able to present real time information,
we kind of jumped on it that way.
One of the core benefits for our product
is that we have real time data directly from
the New York Stock Exchange and NASDAQ
that has data before,
during, and after market.
So, when you have a merger happening
and there's an announcement,
you can get data from 4AM to 8PM
and get real time information.
And it seems like our users
really crave real time,
up to date information
while having a video experience.
Himanshu Patel: So the app contains
basically three sections--
My Stocks, Hot Stocks, and the Videos.
My Stocks is basically a watch list
where you can customize your list.
You can add or delete
your stocks information.
If there's a video label
for any particular symbol,
you can click on the ticker on that
and a video can appear
on the [inaudible] video op panel.
In-between that if you want to go
to the Video or Hot Stocks section,
you can select any particular
symbol and play the video for that.
Scott Drake: For us, we were able
to leverage a lot of our APIs
that we already traditionally had for mobile
and extend that through the Google TV product.
It got us the ability to bring product probably
within a three month cycle to market.
We want information agnostic
whatever platform or device they have.
So, if I enter my personalized
stock information that I care about,
the assets I wanna track,
I can update no matter on a phone
or a tablet or a desktop or a TV.
It follows me
no matter where I am.
And so, as we see,
even in our industry,
a lot of financial professionals
are on the go.
They need that information
following them.
Our audience was really in-sync
with having interaction
and be able to inter-personalize
information, interact with information.
I say any media company that has
an audience that wants to interact
is probably a good candidate
for Google TV.
00:01:57.500,00:00:00.000